I'm an exaustive dad currently owned and
dominated by too many dictators who rule
my life with an iron fist
while wearing their Huggies diapers now
probably because I've been drowning in
small people lately I've been paying
close attention to a particular headline
it seems around the world in developed
countries people are having fewer babies
from North America to Europe to China
Japan there's actually been a consistent
decline in birth rates in fact over the
past 50 years the global fertility rate
has halved what the heck is going on now
my friends who don't want kids all point
to climate change as a reason for never
having babies and many of you are
sitting there right now saying watch
there's also overpopulation
there's also high birth rates which
still exist in many African and Middle
Eastern countries there's also orphan
kids who still need parents there's also
a lack of resources to go around for
everyone and oh by the way we have a
ginormous carbon footprint that is
destroying this planet I hear you I hear
you and yet despite all this chaos I
still think we should have babies I
believe we can and should fight for the
earth and humanity side-by-side now if I
could take it personal for a second I
get it I get why some of you might be
skeptical about having babies all right
here's a photo of my wife and me before
we had kids young happy fresh
here's a photo of me after having kids a
broken defeated husk of a man here's a
photo of the car I thought I'd be
driving as an adult a Porsche here's
what I actually drive a Honda Odyssey
minivan for the minivan where there was
once hope now there is convenient space
and good mileage good mileage now I just
want to stress that I'm completely aware
of the very dire threat of global
warming and climate change I just want
to acknowledge that choosing to have
babies is a deeply profoundly personal
choice and that many who want to are
unable but just for today let's examine
the flip side of the coin and how not
having enough new people is gonna be a
major problem moving forward according
to the World Health Organization we need
to average about 2.1 children per woman
today just so we have enough people to
replace the previous generation a lot of
you thought overpopulation was going to
be a problem in a hundred years yeah it
might be under population so a question
what happens if that number dips below
two point one there's gonna be a domino
effect as all of us get older and live
longer there's gonna be a shrinking
younger population which is gonna lead
to rising labor shortages in the world's
biggest economies I'm talking my United
States China Japan Germany fewer younger
working people means less tax revenue
less tax revenue means less money and
resources to go to safety net programs
that all of us are going to depend upon
I'm talking about pensions and health
care it seems every generation is indeed
connected but how the heck did we get
here in the first place well in some
cases it was intentional let's take the
DeLorean to simpler times let's stop in
China somewhere between the death of
disco and Empire Strikes Back 1980 in
1980 China decided to implement the
one-child policy largely limiting most
parents to having just
one kid to combat overpopulation check
out some good old-fashioned Chinese
propaganda lovely now fast forward to
2019 even after ending its one-child
policy in 2015
China's birth rates have largely
declined in fact the following
population in China is ruling removing
one of its biggest drivers of growth
people if trends continue China's
population is actually going to peak in
2029 before entering quote unstoppable
decline China's government is so freaked
out right now
there's actually doing new propaganda
it's begging couples to have children
for the country let's take the DeLorean
and hop over to Japan home of my beloved
Honda Odyssey minivan Japan is now
producing more adult diapers than infant
once the number of kids in Japan has
fallen for the 37th straight year and
unlike other countries it has not been
able to replace as population numbers
through immigrant workers there will be
labor shortages and not enough money to
fund the safety net programs now Japan
has introduced two solutions first a
financial incentive some local
governments in Japan have offered
couples money to have babies with the
money increasing with each additional
child being born this actually worked
for one year in 2014 in this town called
Alma they actually raised the birth rate
from about one point six six kids per
woman to one point eight but it did not
gain traction across Japan in 2018 a
leader of Japan's ruling party tried a
new tack he told young people you're
selfish for not having babies shockingly
shaming was not a rousing aphrodisiac
surprise I know surprise who'da thought
who would have thought let's take the
DeLorean to Europe the continent of
delicious cheese's I love to eat but
cannot pronounce the UK and much of
Western Europe has a birth rate of about
1.7 kids per woman which at least is
better than hungry where it hovers
around 1.45 now Hungary's Prime Minister
Viktor Orban has proposed a new solution
to try to incentivize people to
have kids he said families where the
women have four or more kids will no
longer pay income tax pretty good right
right pretty good at least it's better
than Russia's 2007 proposal which once
offered women in a particular region the
opportunity of winning a fridge if they
had more kids yeah it didn't work it
didn't work it didn't work what hold on
pump the brakes
orbán is primarily proposing this
because he wants to limit the population
of Muslims and people of color he says
he doesn't think Hungary's traditions
and culture and color has to be quote
mixed with those of others
subtle unfortunately for Orban and much
of the EU the birth rates are not high
enough right now to be replenished
without immigration among EU countries
there is a demographic decline so it
seems in Europe karma is gonna be brown
and Muslim
just think the question remains why
aren't people having enough kids why is
the birthrate declining in these
countries in some cases it's because
women are more literate more educated
they have more economic opportunities
applaud all good things all good things
yes all the things in India this has
been fantastic it has actually reduced
the birthrate but kept it above that
magic two point one number women also
have more access to birth control more
control over their reproductive lives
all good things but in the United States
in particular a lot of young people were
opting out of having kids largely cite
the same reason financial concerns let's
take the DeLorean to my motherland the
United States of America where the birth
rate hit its historic low in 2017 the
United States is the most expensive
country in the world to give birth if
you do not have insurance it will cost
you thirty two thousand dollars to have
a baby if everything goes perfectly
that's like buying a brand-new Honda
Odyssey minivan okay so congratulations
you just had a baby but the baby's
economic productivity is zero and guess
what the United States is the only
industrialized country in the world that
does not require employers to offer paid
parental leave mom
you just had a baby congratulations
that's lovely get back to work or you're
fired young mom my wife and I both
working parents pay about $3,500 a month
a month in Virginia for child care if
you do the math that's $40,000 a year
that's like buying a brand-new souped-up
Honda Odyssey minivan okay I have one I
do not need ten so here's my bold
suggestion let's make it easier for
people to have babies it seems in order
to invest in our future we actually have
to invest in the present and help those
people who want to become parents give
them affordable health care give them
affordable
I'll care give them paid parental leave
among the EU states in 2017 France
reported the highest birth rates why
largely due to its pronatal policies
that actually kept women in the
workforce I'm talking about subsidized
daycare and paid maternal leave China
and Japan thank God are finally wise
inning up and proposing such policies
this is great that being said I know
some of you have listened to me and you
still think the best investment we can
make in the future is not having babies
I respect that I get where you're coming
from
and I know many of you in this audience
want to have babies but you are
terrified about the future and as a
parent I feel you I'm scared about the
future I wrote that last line a month
ago but it really hit home three days
ago for me while I was at Ted three days
ago my wife calls me crying I pick it up
in my hotel room and she said I'm
calling from the hospital we had to take
my baby daughter new ceiba who's named
after a warrior princess to the hospital
because she found a bump on the stomach
we got back the results and there were
bumps all around her liver today this
morning we found out that she has stage
4 liver cancer
it has been a challenging week it has
been a challenging week and if I may I
just want to take a moment to
acknowledge the Ted staff everyone top
down everyone in the back in the green
room some of the speaker's word has
spread on behalf of my family my wife
and my parents my Pakistani parents ed I
had to say this thank you for just being
decent and kind this week so thank you
thank you
these are my beloved's my Ibrahim and no
Sabra my babies I talked to my wife and
despite the terrible news and the fight
ahead
we both concluded that we were get
nothing deciding to have babies was the
best decision we ever made our babies
have brought us so much joy and they've
brought the world so much joy and having
kids is a risk but life is a risk and
yes I hope you've been paying attention
we need to invest in babies in developed
countries if we want to help save our
economy and pensions but that's not the
reason you have babies that's not the
main reason babies have always
represented humanity's best boldest most
beautiful infinite possibilities and if
we in developed countries as a whole opt
out and don't invest in present future
generations and what the hell is the
point what's the point of being on this
absurd journey together and so for those
who can and who choose to for those who
can and who choose to have kids may you
pass on this beautiful thing called life
with kindness generosity decency and
love thank you
[Applause]